[Applause]
ryan my boy brian said well he said i
think
lamar is james harden
why is that first of all they play the
game like nobody we've really seen
before yeah i get this level
but there's just a goat that's always
there that's going to be in the way
which for heart and his curry
for muhammad for uh lamar's mahomes and
also in big games they just don't seem
to show up
it just seems like they're so good in
the regular season like you can people
are defending lamar because like
i guess a lot is asked of him they don't
have good receivers you're an mvp
i can't hold you to the standard of like
even dak prescott who's good but not an
mvp
yeah you are a [ __ ] mvp that's a game
changer
you are the player in the league that
changes everything
i don't care if it's ten to three and
you don't have good results and you
throw the pick six
yeah and now 17-3 that's on you yeah and
that's against tennessee he didn't do
well last year in the playoffs
his first playoff game he played badly
it's his first game but like if it don't
if you don't figure out real quick
you're just james harden to me you're
not poisonous you're a good you seem
like everybody loves you
but you know what's interesting though
about like especially what happened
yesterday in the tampa bay game like
we're gonna give tom all this credit for
winning the game
yeah but he's a defense he's playing he
kind of won that game right bail him out
he had like 190 yards
yeah and he had a horrible first half
yeah started to kind of like string it
together a little bit maybe towards the
end of the first
and in the second the saints defense is
good though they're like yeah
maybe the best in the league they're
okay good yeah yeah but still he
struggled in the first half
and that's where i worry i'd love to see
him beat the pack yeah i would just love
to see tom brady go to the [ __ ] super
bowl i'd be so lit and gronk
is non-existent yeah he's old man i
think you're
a year off too and football is different
than a year off in any way yeah you were
saying that on another episode that like
so yeah he doesn't look the same
he doesn't i mean they were going to
what's the other guy where tight end
they have uh uh cameron braid i think
something like that yeah
break is it other white boy big white
boy and like he was getting way more
touches man i'm sure there's much more
attention put on girl he's good though
but he is good yeah but gronkowski it
seems like his role now is to block
and apparently he's very good at that
but he's still a red zone threat because
he's just huge right and they're right
he went at him a couple times
it was like okay one was on tom yeah the
other looked like the speed kind of
wasn't yeah he could have caught it but
it's not it's not there antonio brown
still looks pretty good but not
antonio brown injured did you see
something did he get hurt he did pull up
and is he going to be out i i it's
monday so they're not going to say but
like if he's out that's big
because he was starting to kind around
in the form still not the same guy
but starting to kind of round into form
football is just different i think
taking a year off in such a physical
fast-paced
constantly evolving game yeah i don't
often see people come back from a year
off and act like nothing happened it
happens but it's
rare yeah rare all right um
you brought a pardon yeah
i think this hardened situation
is absolutely genius for the nets
brilliant i think it's so brilliant
i think that hardin doesn't want to be a
one he doesn't want to be the number one
guy that's true he doesn't want to be
that alpha and i kind of noticed this
when i would watch like all-star games
and i'd see him kind of like take that
beta roll to
you know lebron or kd
or the other guys that were out there he
kind of like removed himself even like a
giannis
you know and i was like okay he doesn't
really want it want it but when he's on
his team where he has to
he'll go out and do it but that's not
the role he really relishes
the fact that he's on a team where he
gets to be in number two a comfy number
two
and where he gets to delegate
responsibilities to guys who can
actually score
a kd can actually do it himself if he
needs great situation
but the reason why it's brilliant is is
because
kyrie has to play now
explain if kd
and hardin can do it without kyrie
and kyrie is useless you're useless now
you
have to play to be part of this if you
continue the shenanigans you're not
needed you get waived you get traded
you could you could maybe they could
make an argument to the league that like
you're violating your contract
they can figure something out but you
are not needed now so in order to be
part of this
you better play ball before they needed
kyrie to go deep in the playoffs now
they don't need kyrie to go deep in
places
it's a brilliant chess move that's a
good point how do you make kyrie commit
make him useless here's where i worry
about it yeah
i think you're right uh for harden
durant give give him the ball
and the big moments that's such a
[ __ ] burden awful hard i don't think
he wants it
i think he wants to go party durant's
gonna play ball kyrie though is not
gonna be comfortable as a number three i
don't think he's not gonna
but it's the only way to get him to
commit and the only way to remove his
leverage over the organization
is to just remove his power and his
power is you need him to win
now you don't need him to win you can go
into the playoffs in pretty deep
with harden and kd you add kyrie
now we're at the championship yeah i
think they're better without him
i've never been a kairi no but now that
they've lost their bench they need him
oh that's right because they just sent
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
no bench i mean nobody would trade for
him right because if you could trade him
for role players i would do that [ __ ] so
fast
in a heartbeat so fast cause hardin and
katie's a crazy squad what's up
pretty impressive though first game did
you see harden's before and after
pictures
yeah that was a little like i think it
was altered a little bit
yeah i think they're just like there's
no there's no way you could lose that
much weight yeah you're like taking the
fattest looking
shot of him bro this is really sensitive
about harden by the way
yeah why why because we're in the
elevator i'm sitting there with dove
alex and bob just looked at him and goes
alex you you kind of look like james
harden you know
literally the week before james had all
those pictures of him super fast
that is funny oh that's disrespectful
dope didn't even mean it
that's the best part he meant it was
like a cop yeah he was like yeah you
look like an nba player
yeah and they don't look at anything in
life yeah look nothing alike
beard you're not even in the same [ __ ]
so my question is what's it gonna take
for you to be a nets fan that's what i
was wondering
nothing bro why not what did you lose
no but you already jumped you already
dropped the knicks
yeah cheer no gear oh you're a heat fan
no i go cheering
[Laughter]
hey that's not a bad idea i go cheer no
gear what does that mean
meaning like i will cheer for the nets
i'll watch the games but i won't ever
buy
any merch or anything like that or
paraphernalia you've done that with the
cowboys for three years it does nothing
really no no no meaning like
like you're still a cowboys fan yeah but
you you root for another team and
therefore
no i just don't i'm not buying anything
i'm not going to your games no what i'm
saying is
i will root for the nets
really yeah like i want them to win i
think it's cool it's good for the city
it'd be great to have you know winning
basketball in the city you're right
there but i can't put the hat on bro
right there yo yeah you're wearing the
colors oh we live in brooklyn now
so i live in my it's still early enough
for me to bandwagon i'm team new york
new york all day baby yeah you grew up
in brooklyn i mean it is
stupid to have this loyalty
like that yeah like at least you're
still loyal you can be loyal to new york
new york you really want to make the
knicks better you abandon them
be a nets fan whoa that's years that's
three years
nah bruh three years if the knicks don't
get it together you're good you're never
seen
other people i'm not easy you know what
i mean i'm that easy
yeah you can steal me buy some of them
seasoned tickets yeah
let's go but we can't even watch a
[ __ ] game bro
now you can get them probably real cheap
that's a good point we're always looking
for the deal brooklyn [ __ ] though that
when they finally have the squad
everyone wants to see
we won't go to the game bro oh [ __ ] dude
they would be
selling out man imagine there was no
that's what i'm saying
get in now because aren't you locked in
at a price he's right
he's right i don't know if you locked in
at a price but you're locked into
first option so like basically if you're
a season ticket holder not only do you
get the playoff tickets the first option
but every year they call you like would
you like to re-up your seats yeah did
you
do that so we could essentially get in
there
car lenses was my hookup but i don't
know if that's gonna happen anymore
he might get me front row to mecca
but now he used to be my next hookup man
[ __ ] come on jets tickets they got that
muslim coach they just hired robert
solomon
son the jets bro we got to talk about
robbie's joke
robbie son did he send you a joke
robbie slovick is one of the writers on
um saves america uh
the greatest comedy special to ever hit
netflix
in netflix's history okay beautifully
directed
unbelievably directed okay uh
now robbie i got to get this this robbie
texts us a joke okay he sends it to the
group
yeah mark do we have it god damn it
now set up what happened uh
so the new york jets hired the san
francisco 49ers defensive coordinator
he's a good coordinator his name is
robert sala
black but also the first muslim nfl head
coach
yep so in history yeah so he's coaching
for the new york jets right
and um robbie just texts us immediately
after the news breaks
he goes uh hope it goes better than the
last time
muslims teamed up with jets in new york
and he said he's like no i got a new
podcast coming out in a month i'm gonna
drop it there i'm like
robbie what are you doing bro i
literally was so angry
that he didn't tweet it i texted him
this morning i said have you said the
joke on any
twitter you know i was like can i tell
people the joke on the podcast today
he's like yeah fine you can do it
you